what's going on guys this is Rob and and
I just wanted to say you guys are
awesome you guys were amazing I was I
was working on the second half of the
Thanos Quest video which of course is
the the time Jim and the power Jim and I
finished the video and I was just
sitting here thinking for a second like
I just sat here for a minute or two and
I was like man like like I'm making
comic book videos to put on YouTube this
is awesome and you know and I just I
don't know maybe he just hit me maybe
just kind of occurred to me but you know
it's it's just this idea that you guys
are amazing and I've always said that
you know I've always said that that you
guys are pretty cool you know because
it's because of you guys because of the
fact you guys upload or I guess I'll
post videos all over the interwebs you
know all the Internet's and you know
because you guys you know tell your
friends and people that you know about
the videos that I make you know that my
channel has grown so much it's because
of all the positive support you guys
have given me and and for that I don't
know if I could ever really thank you
guys enough I don't know if I could ever
really say enough times you guys are
great because of that
you know because you know I think that
one of the things people forget you know
was on YouTube you can upload content
all day long but if there's nobody there
to receive it if nobody cares about it
nobody shows you support by posting your
videos everywhere then you know it
doesn't really do anything to help you
grow and I think the subscribers are a
bigger part of a youtube channel being
successful than content you know course
subscribers you know you guys Drive
content but you know it's just I don't
know it's just it's just one of these
least interesting things but you know I
just want to take this time to say that
I appreciate everything that you guys
have done to help me grow so far and and
you guys are awesome because of that
you know it's just things are moving so
fast you know the time is approaching
when I'd be able to do this like for a
living like make videos about comic
books and bring you guys all kinds of
information about all kinds of
characters and storylines and all kinds
of stuff you know and and it's something
that I'm really looking forward to you
know it's a time that I'm really excited
for you know that that you know in the
future of this channel you know they'll
be like meetups you know I'll just be
like hey guys I'm gonna be and I don't
know like Detroit and does everybody
want to hang out you know or I'll be in
you know like Seattle you know is
anybody want to hang out or something
like that or Comic Cons you know or
whatever but you know it'll be a chance
to like hang out and meet with you guys
face-to-face and be like what's up you
know maybe like me to the comic book
store or something like that you know
this it's just it's a really exciting
time you know it's a really really it's
a really fun thing and you know I think
that this is what makes this is I don't
mean to sound melodramatic here but I
think it's it's times like these that
make life worth living you know what I
mean not to say that my god I didn't
think life is worth living before but
it's it's times like these where you you
engage in an action you engage in some
kind of a project and you receive such
overwhelming support from people that
you're just like all you can really do
is just sit back and just be like wow
wow like I mean yeah you know it's just
one of those kind of things so you know
I mean we're we're growing so fast I
mean I've been doing this since about
December so maybe a little bit earlier
but you know it wasn't until like
February that it just BAM took off and
so you know over the past however many
months what is that February March April
May June July August September over the
last eight months like we've we've grown
like crazy I mean almost
when is that three four thousand
subscribers a month or something like
that and you know that I think
averages out to and we're just growing
more and more and it's just it's fun
it's amazing to to just I don't know to
be a part of all this you know with you
know I look at everything that's going
on you know I look at it you know the
the growth of my channel and Vinnies
Channel and South Channel and Dave's
Channel you know and and it's funny to
sit down and to say you know like I
never would have met these guys you know
had it not been for like you all you
know had it not been for you guys being
so supportive and spurring me on to
expand and to get out and then meet new
people none of this ever would have
happened and so you know I look to the
future of projects and stuff that you
know that we're gonna get into do that
me and the guys are gonna get into and I
look at like all the stuff that we're
gonna do you know and and all the things
that are on the horizon you know that
that are in the future for this for this
channel and their channels and and so on
and it's just it's a very exciting time
you know and and you know I would like
to say that maybe you know what we're
doing here on YouTube maybe our
explanations of comics in the way that
we do it will pave the way for other
great youtubers you know and will pave
the way for other youtubers out there
right now who were great and just don't
get a whole lot of exposure to get the
exposure they deserve to get the
recognition they deserve because of the
content they put up you know and to see
this this comic book community on
YouTube just becomes something massive
words it's more than just these general
discussions on the top ten coming book
characters or the top ten storylines or
you know here are the list of things
that you missed and a new Marvel
Cinematic Universe film you know where
it becomes this big giant universe I
don't know maybe I'm having this great
big grand dreams I have no idea but all
I know is that at the moment at this
point in time 2:40 a.m. on September 3rd
that you guys are amazing so we're not
going say I'm gonna end this video um
the Thanos quest part 2 will be uploaded
today it is Wednesday so it'll be
uploaded probably around noon and I
don't know maybe a little bit later I'm
not exactly sure but it'll be uploaded
today at some point in time and and yeah
so I'll catch you guys later peace